ich kann nicht von streaming leben seit
corona kann ich halt nur von meinem
ersparten leben und das finde ich es
eigentlich der skandal
bei wiener ist seit rund zehn jahren im
musikgeschäft und gerade dabei richtig
durchzustarten
sie hat bereits vier alben
veröffentlicht gerade wird sie aber nur
online gehört und hier liegt für sie das
große problem musikstreaming bringt der
sängerin kein geld in den kommenden
wochen will bei wiener mir zeigen wie
viel arbeit in nur einem einzigen song
steckt im studio nimmt sie heute den
gesang zu ihrem neuen song auf spotify
hat bei biener circa 15.000 monatliche
hörer innen
damit gehört sie wie sie es selbst nennt
zum künstlerischen mittelstand spotify
ist der markt für und damit die
wichtigste plattform für bei biener wie
viel verdient die sängerin an einem
klick das ist ein bruchteil von einem
cent also ich gucken meine abrechnung
noch nicht mal an für die paar kröten
brauche ich mir das nicht weniger als
einen cent pro klick das macht mal ist
kaum mehr als eine tafel schokolade im
monat
normalerweise verdient sie ihr geld aus
zwei quellen live konzerte und musik
streaming
doch genau dort wo sie die meisten fans
erreicht verdient sie fast nichts und
wenn man überlegt hatte am ende des
tages bei musik streaming pro klick
bekommst die das im verhältnis also du
machst du machst nicht für streaming
sondern du machst das halt für die mucke
einmal und dann für live halten weil du
es live dann präsentieren kannst da wir
im moment nicht spielen können es
natürlich die frage christian für was
machen wir das jetzt hier also wenn man
es anfängt auf den kopf gestern dass die
ja dann brauchst du gar nicht aufstehen
toningenieur christian prommer ist für
den sound zuständig bis zur
veröffentlichung des songs dauert es
noch fast zwei monate
ja ich höre mich gut das ist super das
klage ankommen
mir den himmel
ich kämpfe nicht gegen streaming ich
finde das ist das genialste konstrukte
was wir seit der piraterie haben es gibt
so viel geld zur verteilung rund 160
millionen nutzer haben ein monatliches
abo allein bei spotify im jahr 2020
wurden in der gesamten branche allein
mit musik streaming circa zwölf
milliarden euro erwirtschaftet und
trotzdem kommt bei balbina und vielen
anderen musikern so gut wie nichts an
woran liegt das ist die sängerin einfach
zu unbekannt hat sie zu wenige fans und
damit zu wenig klicks wie sieht es bei
den top stars aus
das will ich wissen und zwar von einem
richtig großen künstler von peter maffay
über
die wand
[Musik]
er ist einer der erfolgreichsten
deutschen musik stars bei biener
begleitet mich sie ist genauso gespannt
ob es dem star besser geht als ihr wir
sind alle getestet und können uns
deswegen treffen
[Musik]
sie steht peter maffay ist seit über 50
jahren erfolgreich im musikgeschäft bei
spotify hat er über 800.000 monatliche
hörerinnen und hörer könnt ihr von musik
streaming allein leben für mich jetzt
nicht wirklich geld verdienen nicht so
dass man das als grundlage als
ökonomische grundlage betrachten kann
das ist minimal
[Musik]
zwei musiker zwei generationen aber ein
und dasselbe problem wie kammern fall
darf aus vertraglichen gründen keine
konkreten zahlen zu seinen einnahmen bei
musik streamen nennen doch er macht uns
glaubhaft es sei verdammt wenig warum es
ist ihnen so wichtig dieses thema
anzusprechen und müssen mit diesem thema
an die öffentlichkeit zu gehen weil ich
ungerecht finde was überhaupt passiert
ganz japan so und jahres ist 17 und
machte auch musik und hat einen weg vor
sich
ich wünschte mir er wie tausende andere
haben eine chance
von dem zu leben
was sie sich erzeugen
mit musik streaming ist das für newcomer
und künstlerinnen wie bei biener kaum
möglich der grund ist das aktuelle
bezahlsystem der streaming dienste und
das funktioniert so ein beispiel
marie hört gern deutschrap den ganzen
tag kurzes songs rauf und runter sie
klickt über 10.000 mal im monat frank
hingegen wird gern klassik da er nur
selten musik hört und jedes stück sehr
lang ist generiert er nur wenig streams
und kommt gerade mal auf 10 klicks im
monat beide marie und frank zahlen 10
euro abo gebühren im monat
die einnahmen wandern in einen topf der
streamingdienst behält ein drittel also
über sechs euro
die verbleibenden rund 14 euro werden
nach der häufigkeit der streams
aufgeteilt der rapper den marie mag
bekommt fast die gesamten abogebühren
auch das geld von franken und der
klassik künstler nun der kriegt für die
zehn klicks gerade mal einen cent
es geht nämlich nicht darum was man hört
es geht darum wie häufig man es hat das
heißt nur repetitive konsum führt auch
zu ertrag
anders als beim kauf einer cd
unterstützen wir beim streaming also
nicht direkt die künstler die wir hören
[Musik]
also in technischer hinsicht ist das was
da etabliert wurde ein meisterwerk
es ist nur geradezu geschaffen kürzer
auszubeuten
benutze dieses wort ganz wesentlich
auszubeuten ausbeuten damit meint peter
maffay alle musikerinnen und musiker die
mit streaming nichts verdienen und
trotzdem ihre musik den portalen zur
verfügung stellen
und das ist die große mehrheit beim
blick auf die webseite von spotify sehe
ich sie haben mehr als acht millionen
künstler aber nur 57.000 von innen
erhalten 90 prozent der einnahmen
weniger als ein prozent
die meisten verdienen weniger als 1000
dollar im ganzen jahr
peter maffay findet das nicht fair
deswegen kämpft er für eine faire
bezahlung im musik streaming gemeinsam
mit stars wie sarah connor und den
ärzten hat er sich der initiative fair
share angeschlossen
auf der webseite verweist die initiative
auf ein weiteres problem manipulation
aber wie soll das funktionieren
darüber möchte ich mehr erfahren sabina
kennt einen musiker der bekannt ist und
ein dubioses angebot erhalten hat rapper
maeckes
[Musik]
sag ich mal
auch merkels kritisiert das aktuelle
abrechnungsmodell im musik streamen
denn am meisten auf an musik dass man
also hinter vorgehaltener hand hört dass
andere leute unfassbar viel geld
verdienen das heißt man braucht
unglaublich viele fleißige fans einfach
ganz oft klicken oder ganz oft hören
kannst du gut man braucht eine armee
wenn ich heutzutage eine sehr
disziplinierte armee am besten cyber
armee ob das jetzt ein echter klick ist
oder kein echter klick klick klick
bisher eine cyber armee keine echten
klicks mcus erzählt mir von einem
fragwürdigen angebot ist vor kurzem auch
wie wir so auch im verkauf einfach so
eine die em bekommt von irgendwem
indischen account und mir einfach so hey
hier ist das angebot das ich für dich
habe das belegt das ist es das ist für
kommentare barbar mit seiner
telefonnummer whatsapp per
privatnachricht wurden mcus unechte
klicks gegen bezahlung angeboten ein
verlockendes angebot aber merkels lehnt
ab ist es wirklich so einfach sich
erfolg bei spotify zu kaufen
das will ich selbst herausfinden und
wende mich an peter maffay seinen
berater daniel maurer und an den
wissenschaftler patrick von der raum
guten morgen guten morgen große ehre ich
würde ja gerne um autogramm bitten aber
ich weiß nicht wie das geht und zum
digitalen kontext
ich bin sehr gerne mein plan für rund
700 euro durch eine halbe million klicks
kaufen und zwar für maffays song die
geister die ich rief
[Musik]
ein eher unbekannter song denn keiner so
richtig kennt genau deshalb will ich ihn
jetzt zu einem der meist gespielten
lieder von peter maffay machen
mit seinem einverständnis kaufe ich die
klicks eine kurze google-suche bezahlen
mit kreditkarte fertig ich erhalte keine
bestätigung alles läuft anonym
im impressum finde ich keinen namen und
keine adresse der betreiber soll
angeblich in russland sitzen wird uns
das experiment gelingen zwischen ich
will noch einmal denken sie das ist von
dieser manipulation etwas bemerken wird
also dass spotify das bemerkt dass davon
würde ich ja mal ganz stark ausgehen ja
die frage ist wie damit umgegangen wird
also wenn herausgefunden wird dass es
sich um eine manipulation handeln könnte
dann musste der weg eigentlich so sein
dass sony music das label von peter
maffay fließt das geld von spotify an
den künstler
ich bin gespannt ob das auffällt und ob
sich sony bei peter maffay melden wird
ich kann es immer noch nicht glauben ist
es so einfach
zu kaufen
seitdem ich die unechten klicks gekauft
habe sind drei wochen vergangen mit
peter maffay will ich wissen hat unser
experiment funktioniert deshalb das
ergebnis dabei sehr gespannt
ist es uns gelungen den bisher
unbekannten song die geister die ich
rief zu einem der meist gehörten maffay
songs zu machen
das ist ein anstieg von über 10.000
prozent orten 10.000 genau das
experiment hat funktioniert nach drei
wochen haben wir 200.000 unechte klicks
generiert 300.000 fehlen noch und jeden
tag kommen immer mehr dazu
die geister die ich rief hat es sogar
unter die top 5 der beliebtesten lieder
von peter maffay bei spotify geschafft
wir können sogar sehen woher die abrufe
kommen
man kann hier erkennen dass die meisten
klicks tatsächlich aus den usa kam fast
170 da unglaublich ich musste mich dass
wir dort gehört was mich wundert zum
zeitpunkt unserer auswertung sind wieder
spotify noch sony eingeschritten
was denken sie was für die reaktion von
spotify sein wenn sie jetzt davon
erfahren
im drastischsten fall kann ich mir
vorstellen würde das partie vor allem
mit sperren ja wenn das der fall ist ist
das eine konsequenz mit der ich leben
kann und auch gerne leben will weil es
geht mir um aufklärung
es geht also nicht um macht es geht um
am prinzip welches hier verletzten und
manipulation notes ich durchschnitts
berechnungen zeigen pro klick verdient
man bei spotify ungefähr 0,3 cent für
eine halbe million klicks hätten wir
also ungefähr 1500 euro verdient was
wird mit den einnahmen aus diesem lied
basieren
dieses geld können wir nicht annehmen
weil es manipuliert zustande gekommen
ist
das heißt wenn wir es akzeptieren würde
hier ist anderen klar
ganz einfach
wir wollen wir nicht
einen tag nach meinem besuch bei peter
maffay informiere ich sony und spotify
über unsere manipulation während sie
bisher kein interesse an unserem thema
hatten klappt es auf einmal doch ich
kann mit dem europa-chef von spotify
sprechen und konfrontiere michael krause
mit unserem experiment
etwas mitgebracht netterweise die das
management von beta macht zur verfügung
gestellt was sehen sie da da sehe ich so
weit ich das beurteilen kann ein auszug
aus einem unserer tools die wir unseren
künstlern zur verfügung stellen wo man
die abrufe der stream sehen kann von
einem produkte neben fall eines
einzelnen liedes was kann man erkennen
genauer kann erkennen das ist ein
wachstum dieses titels gibt es kann sein
dass zb eine promotion stattgefunden
habe dass der künstler oder die
künstlerin im fernsehen aufgetreten ist
oder unsere fall war das jetzt keine
werbung und da keine promotion sondern
wir haben tatsächlich ein echter klicks
nicht auf haben sie auch von diesen
speziellen fall etwas mitbekommen
aufgefallen
genau das ist relativ schnell
aufgefallen unser team hat das entdeckt
und hat auch die playlisten aus denen
diese abrufe entstanden sind bereits
gelöscht und wann ist das geschehen
ende mai anfang juni war dass ich kann
es gar nicht genau sagen wann die
entsprechende e-mail an die sony
gegangen ist aber genau möglichst
zeitnah natürlich immer fakt ist wir
haben drei wochen manipuliert dann sony
und spotify davon informiert diese
information gab man auch an sony weiter
wie man uns dort bestätigt sony teilt
uns zudem mit dass sie durch spotify
normalerweise einmal im monat über
festgestellte betrügereien informiert
würden
trotz manipulation wird peter maffay
nicht von spotify gesperrt bekommt für
die manipulierten abrufe aber auch kein
geld aber solange die häufigkeit der
clicks zählt bleibt manipulieren für
künstler innen attraktiv
es gibt ja noch stimmen aus der
musikindustrie das bezahlmodell auf ein
anderes modell umzustellen
was halten sie von diesem vorschlag wir
sind da absolut offen also wir finden
das modell
prinz ich will auch spannend es müssen
natürlich erstens alle marktteilnehmer
in auch einig sein das ist ja ein sehr
komplexes gebilde aus
verwertungsgesellschaften verlagen den
verschiedenen plattenfirmen den dahinter
stehenden künstler in aber wir stehen im
trotzdem sehr offen gegenüber versuchen
dass also die anderen marktteilnehmern
zu verhindern
wie gesagt wir haben die lizenz
beziehungen mit den verschiedenen
marktteilnehmern und wer oder welche
interessen hat kann ich es gar nicht im
detail sagen
spotify sagt sie seien also offen für
alternativmodelle doch bisher kam vom
marktführer noch kein sichtbarer impuls
künstlerinnen wie bei bena bleiben die
leidtragenden in babelsberg bei potsdam
treffe ich die sängerin wieder seit
unserem ersten treffen sind zwei monate
vergangen ihre song produktion ist nun
fast beendet was noch fehlt die
orchester aufnahmen
[Musik]
nach den aufnahmen ziehen wir uns zurück
kurz vor song veröffentlichung hat bei
biener eine klare entscheidung getroffen
also ich habe ja viel kritik an dem
abrechnungssystem von spotify dass
spotify eben etabliert hat und deswegen
habe ich mich dieses mal entschieden den
marktführer spotify nicht zu beliefern
für balbina ist es zwar kein großer
finanzieller verlust dennoch eine harte
entscheidung denn 80 prozent ihrer fans
sind bei spotify aber ohne den klaren
willen der großen anbieter und labels
wird sich nichts ändern
newcomer innen brauchen dafür die
unterstützung von großen namen um druck
ausüben zu können
und solange jeder klick zählt bleibt
auch manipulation weiterhin attraktiv
die geniale erfindung musikstreaming
braucht ein neues faires system
[Musik]